of course talk about your relationship
with with Conway obviously uh you hopped
on scatterbrain which is close to going
gold uh it is yeah I just talked to him
uh earlier last week I think he's gonna
go gold soon yeah
um did you go I know he did that on TV
did you were you on TV with him when you
did that yeah we did it on um I believe
it was Fallon when you see someone like
Conway or just in general like a MC that
you feel like is you know one of them
once like do you feel like kind of like
you know as like almost like a a Jedi
relationship with like certain rappers
where you kind of gotta like reach out
and be like yo I see what you're doing
yeah we I feel like we tapped in and
maybe
2018 just on some like mutual respect I
feel like it was around the time I did
like the funk flesh freestyle yeah and
ever since I feel like we've been tapped
in
um super solid dude but all them guys
over there you know what I'm saying West
Side like
um Bodie all of them they're amazing I
love all these incredible I love all of
them so um
I feel like makami too is he with them
yeah my comics with them crazy you know
what I'm saying streets there's a lot of
crazy stove God Cooks Armani Caesar yeah
they got a dope Camp over this I just
respected I like movements like that
when it's like super based in like the
uh the pure form of like hip-hop I would
say you know